veamos algunos escenarios más
relacionados con el desplazamiento
velocidad y tiempo o distancia rapidez y
tiempo veamos este problema Benito está
corriendo a una velocidad constante de 3
metros por segundo al este cuánto tiempo
le llevará a recorrer 720 metros al este
recordemos algunos conceptos y vamos a
hacer algunos cálculos Bueno aquí
estamos viendo que nos están diciendo
que está yendo a una velocidad de 3
metros por segundo
esto recordemos es una magnitud
ahí magnitud y nos están diciendo Hacia
dónde se dirige
es al este Entonces esto es una
dirección
Así que estamos hablando de vectores
y también nos están diciendo Bueno
cuánto tiempo le llevará a recorrer 720
metros
al este entonces también nos están dando
una magnitud y una dirección y esto
también va a ser un vector
Bueno
recordemos entonces que lo que vimos
vamos a resolver esto tanto para la
versión en escalar como para la versión
en vector de las fórmulas en el video
anterior vimos que
si queremos calcular primero los
escalares
tenemos que la fórmula para calcular la
rapidez
la voy a vivir con una r era igual a la
distancia
entre el tiempo Aunque Bueno aquí más
preciso es el cambio en el tiempo
recordamos que habíamos visto que había
una Delta que indicaba este triangulito
cambio en en este caso cambio en el
tiempo
así que bueno de esta información
tenemos la rapidez ahorita como estamos
viendo escalares no estamos viendo la
dirección entonces tenemos la rapidez es
de 3 metros por segundo
tenemos
Entonces estos son tres metros por
segundo o sobre segundo nos dice Cuál es
la distancia que se quiere recorrer la
distancia es 720 metros
y lo que queremos conocer es el tiempo o
el cambio en el tiempo
Bueno entonces sigamos haciendo cálculos
aquí
y vamos a tener entonces que
Tres metros sobre segundo es igual a 720
metros
entre el tiempo
si multiplicamos todo por el tiempo
nos quedan tiempo por
tres metros sobre segundo igual a
720 metros entre el tiempo por el tiempo
estas unidades se cancelan
nos queda
3 metros sobre segundo por el tiempo es
igual a 720 metros
y lo que queremos conocer
es el tiempo entonces ahora vamos a
dividir ambos lados de la ecuación entre
tres metros
por segundo esto lo dividimos entre tres
metros por segundo y este lado también
720 metros entre 3 metros por segundo
estos se anulan
de este lado me va a quedar el tiempo
y aquí Bueno tenemos 720
entre 3 por metros
entre metros sobre segundo
estas nos quedan 720 entre 3 nos da como
resultado 240 y estas unidades
dividir estos metros entre metros por
segundo es lo mismo que multiplicarlo
por el inverso De esta unidad es lo
mismo que multiplicar metros por segundo
entre metros y esto se anulan y nos
quedan segundos lo que tiene lógica
porque estamos hablando de tiempo
entonces el tiempo aquí serían 240
segundos seguramente en clase verán
muchas fórmulas pero lo que quiero
mostrarles Durante este viaje que
estamos emprendiendo juntos es que
muchas de estas fórmulas son
manipulaciones algebraicas de una u otra
fórmula Así que en lugar de memorizarlas
es mejor que recuerden cómo manipular
algebraicamente las fórmulas originales
las cuales también podemos recordar por
sentido común la rapidez es igual a la
distancia entre el tiempo Esto no es muy
complicado ni muy ilógico y también
pudimos despejar el tiempo directamente
en la fórmula en lugar de hacer todo
este desarrollo
tenemos entonces nuestra fórmula que era
rapidez igual a distancia entre el
tiempo
aquí multiplicamos
por el tiempo
ambos lados de la ecuación Entonces nos
queda tiempo por rapidez igual a
distancia entre el tiempo por el tiempo
se anulan estas unidades
nos quedan
distancias igual al tiempo por la
rapidez y Bueno aquí está de hecho la
distancia la fórmula del movimiento y si
queremos conocer el tiempo entonces
dividimos todo entre la rapidez
distancia entre rapidez es igual a
tiempo por rapidez entre rapidez se
anula esto y nos queda que el tiempo es
igual a la distancia entre la rapidez
que es exactamente lo mismo que hicimos
aquí la distancia 720 metros entre la
rapidez de 3 metros por segundo y nos
quedó este resultado ahora si queremos
hacer exactamente lo mismo pero la
versión de vectores pues nuestra
anotación va a cambiar
Pues ahora vamos a querer llevar un
registro de la dirección del movimiento
Así que podemos decir entonces que ven
nuestra velocidad y aquí indicamos que
es un vector va a ser igual
a nuestro desplazamiento que lo
describimos con la letra s
que es un vector entre el tiempo o el
cambio en el tiempo pero bueno para
mantener un poco más simple estas
fórmulas no voy a usar la Delta lo voy a
referenciar como la t
entonces Bueno
hacemos lo mismo Quiero conocer el
tiempo lo que voy a hacer entonces es
multiplicar ambos lados de la ecuación
por el tiempo tiempo por la velocidad es
igual a el desplazamiento
entre el tiempo por el tiempo se anulan
estos me queda que el desplazamiento es
igual a el tiempo por la velocidad
y ahora despejo multiplicó todo
perdón divido Todo por la velocidad
Entonces tengo el desplazamiento entre
la velocidad
igual a tiempo por velocidad entre
velocidad
estos se anulan y me queda la fórmula de
que el tiempo es igual a el
desplazamiento
entre la velocidad
Así que ahora sí podemos sustituir y nos
queda que el tiempo es igual a nuestro
desplazamiento
3 metros sobre segundo al este
entre la velocidad
que fue de
Perdón no estoy equivocando al revés
arriba es el desplazamiento
720 metros al este Esta es la lo que
tengo que poner aquí
720 metros al este
al este
y esto lo voy a dividir Ahora sí entre
mi velocidad que eran tres metros sobre
segundo al este
Ok entonces bueno se anulan estas
referencias porque bueno el tiempo no
tiene una dirección
me quedan igual 720 entre 3 Metros entre
metros sobre segundo que esto recordamos
es lo mismo que este
multiplicar
esta m por la inverso de estas unidades
de segundos entre metros y me quedan
segundos y esto me queda igual a 240
segundos igual que en este resultado
porque Les comento aunque estamos
hablando con trabajando con vectores el
tiempo no tiene una dirección
propiamente y aquí también quisiera
hacerles una nota o una aclaración Ya
que en los últimos problemas hemos
indicado la dirección de vectores
diciendo al norte o al oeste o al este y
ustedes verán que cuando veamos
problemas más complicados como los que
se pueden encontrar en una clase típica
de física Es que se define una
convención Por ejemplo yo puedo decir
que la dirección positiva
y sobre todo esto sirve cuando estamos
tratando con dimensiones con una
dimensión cuando algo solo puede avanzar
o retroceder o ir de izquierda a derecha
Aunque Bueno también se puede usar con
otras cuando trabajamos con varias
dimensiones Aquí hacemos convenciones
como que este valor positivo lo vamos a
tener todas las direcciones que van al
este vamos a trabajarlas como
direcciones positivas y las negativas
van a ser las que van al oeste
aquí como son 700 metros 720 metros al
este bueno es una dirección positiva
300 metros sobre segundo al este también
es una dirección positiva por esta
convención por eso mi resultado es
positivo
esta manejo de estas convenciones
compositivo y negativo me ayudan porque
la mismos cálculos matemáticos me van a
indicar cuál es la dirección resultante
entonces bueno Esto es mucho más
práctico en algún momento para poder
saber cuál es la dirección este de
nuestro resultado final Pero esto lo
vamos a ver más adelante